Esse
[Música]
é o primeiro volume alto de escrever
para que pessoas cegas e com baixa visão
possam ter uma ideia de quem tá falando
eu sou uma mulher branca se gênero
cabelo preto curto tô usando óculos com
ar marrom do vestido uma blusa azul
claro igual a alta e atrás de mim tem
uma estante de livros
eu também sou da scuderia daí a Sandra
lei de Campos Bueno então eu quero me
dirigir primeira real peço licença a sua
benção
bom exceto por ser molhar tudo que o Edu
e eu descemos sobre mim Ah até aqui se
refere a condições de vida que me
colocam em posição de Privilégio em
relação a maioria da população
brasileira e latino-americana e eu
costumo dizer que privilégio é um lugar
quentinho macio e cheiroso e essa frase
engraçada tem tudo a ver com que eu vim
falar que hoje no teu ex lançador que a
relação entre racismo e privilégio e o
que nós pessoas brancas fazemos com isso
para nós brancas e brancos
e geralmente o racismo é um assunto dos
outros são os outros que cometem racismo
que agridem pessoas com xingamentos por
exemplo mas a gente não pensa que o
racismo tem tudo a ver com os nossos
privilégios os nossos próprios
privilégios
na minha área de pesquisa tem um monte
desses exemplo eu pesquiso a
participação política das mulheres com
enfoque interseccional de raça e gênero
A ideia é que quando eu digo que é
injusto que mulheres sejam 52 por cento
da população mas que estejam só em
quinze por cento dos cargos políticos
como vereadores deputados prefeitos
governadores e outros cargos Eu também
preciso dizer que mulheres negras são 55
porcento da população feminina no Brasil
mas que a maioria das mulheres que estão
naqueles cargos são brancas
bom então se eu falo de mulheres na
política eu não posso falar só de gênero
no Brasil e na América Latina e eu
preciso combinar a sujeira uma vez eu
encontrei dois documentos oficiais um
falava sobre paridade de gênero na
política e usava só o termo mulheres sem
considerar a raça e o outro falava sobre
mulheres negras indígenas e uma das
propostas esse documento era que se
aumentasse a formalização do trabalho
doméstico remunerado os dois documentos
estão sendo discutidos na mesma época e
no mesmo fórum no mesmo espaço formado
por mulheres brancas no organismo
Regional que o Brasil participa e tudo
bem querer a paridade na política Eu
também quero tudo bem que é a
formalização do trabalho doméstico
remunerado Mas a pergunta que pulava da
tela era porque quando a gente fala de
igualdade na política as mulheres não
tem raça e quando a gente fala de
trabalho doméstico o resultado Essas
Mulheres sempre são negras indígenas
e no Brasil por exemplo dados de pé de
2018 mostram que setenta por cento das
mulheres empregadas no trabalho
doméstico remunerado são negras e trinta
por cento são brancos dados do TSE do
mesmo ano mostram que em 2018 das
mulheres eleitas quase setenta por cento
um Branca quase trinta por cento eram
negras e só uma mulher indígena foi
eleita a deputada Federal a primeira na
história a deputado DNA o aptiano
percebem como essas duas proposições
tiver tem percebem que mesmo na
desigualdade de gênero oficina existe e
sim precisa ser resolvida mulheres
brancas estão em posição de privilégio
é isso não vale só para minha área isso
vale para qualquer área qualquer os
patins fica oficial vai mostrar que
nesse país as desigualdades sociais são
suportadas majoritariamente por pessoas
negras indígenas
participação política trabalho e renda
moradia saneamento básico saúde educação
violência eu podia ficar horas a fio
falando desses dados em todos eles
pessoas brancas têm melhores condições
de vida e isso é privilégio privilégio
que o dicionário Michaelis
define da seguinte forma eu vou ler para
vocês é uma posição de superioridade
amparada ou não por lei ou costumes de
corrente da distribuição desigual do
poder político ou econômico
e nós pessoas brancas sabemos que tem os
privilégios a gente não precisa estudar
estatísticas nem essas desigualdades
sociais para saber primeiro poder nos
beneficiamos deles todos os dias e
depois porque é só abrir as redes
sociais Ligar a tv olhar para o lado e
perceber
não ter moradia digna fazer uma refeição
a cada 2 dias ser seguido e até agredido
no supermercado tem uma filha e um filho
morto a tiros na porta de casa
para muitos de nós brancos e brancos e
se não faz parte da vida a gente tá
confortavelmente protegido pelos nossos
privilégios
falar abertamente assim desse jeito que
eu tô falando indo na raiz vendo uma
base ética que eu aprendi com aí a
Sandra Lia e a sua radicalidade amorosa
que ela trouxe a química da Costa do ano
passado a gente se acostumou a viver
nesse lugar quentinho uma silhueta O
Privilégio e esse lugar não é ruim não é
mesmo é bom não passar dificuldades é
bom não sofrer violência é o que todo
mundo quer não é mesmo mas poucas
pessoas têm
Então se a gente quer de verdade uma
sociedade Justa e igualitária a gente
precisa se mexer desse lugar a gente
precisa fazer bem mais do que usar foto
de perfil toda preta de novembro e
novembro e compartilhar hashtag das
negras importam nas redes sociais a
gente precisa fazer mais do que a doação
mensal daquele projeto social que
trabalha com mulheres negras periférica
a gente precisa fazer mais do que
comprar camiseta da ONG que trabalha em
comunidade indígena
é isso não tá errado ainda mais agora
nessa é porque de aumento de violência e
Miséria mas ainda assim é muito pouco a
gente precisa sair do centro a gente
precisa dar um passo atraso a gente
precisa brigar antes passo a gente
precisa escutar a gente precisa
exercitar escuta a gente igualdades
sociais e os dados estatísticos que eu
falei agora pouco não são nenhuma
novidade
isso vem sendo denunciado dito e
repetido por pessoas negras indígenas há
muito tempo e a gente não escuto a gente
não arreda pé do privilégio
inclusive de não fazer nada ou quase
nada uma vez aí a Sandra lhe fez um
chamado as pessoas brancas era março de
2018 no ato Por Justiça para Marielle
Franco e Anderson Gomes numa esquina
democrática lotado de gente no Porto
Alegre em determinado momento ela se
dirigiu A Branca de brancos e disse
brancos sejam os nossos escudos
na hora eu não sabia muito bem como mas
eu tinha certeza que eu queria podia
fazer aquilo eu tava iniciando mestrado
tinha que escolher o tema Tava bem na
época de escolher o tema da pesquisa eu
já trabalhava com direito das mulheres
com violência de gênero e participação
política e eu me inclinar por esse
último eu podia muito bem ter ficado só
no geral ninguém igual a mim achar ruim
É mas o meu privilégio de poder estudar
e trabalhar com uma certa tranquilidade
foi uma forma de atender esse chamado de
ar a convocação da Assembleia de dar um
passo atrás de mexer no meu privilégio
de mulher branco eu continuo querendo
igualdade de gênero na política depois
disso continua assim eu quero qualidade
quero metade mulheres ainda tarde homem
mas eu não quero que os espaços sejam
mais um lugar de Privilégio para
mulheres e homens brancos eu quero
qualidade racializados na medida da
igualdade de raça e gênero por isso que
a paridade na política que eu pesquise
proponho combina raça e gênero e eu faço
isso escutando e lendo preferencialmente
mulheres negras não foi por acaso não
foi para o sorte que eu encontrei
estudei a declaração das mulheres negras
e indígenas
latino-americanas presentes na 13ª
conferência Regional sobre a mulher que
e dá um 2016 com mais ou menos uns dois
anos antes daqueles dois documentos
falar sobre paridade e trabalho
doméstico remunerado
em uma demanda das dessas mulheres
negras e indígenas para as mulheres
brancas era Justamente a garantia da sua
representação política e pública e elas
diziam pela atualizar ambiência honesto
para nos outras
Olá tudo isso que eu falei aqui que eu
contei para vocês é a só Minha
experiência pessoal
então se tu é branca ou branco
e com certeza tem alguma forma de tu tá
mexendo que lugar de Privilégio de um
passo atrás e tem desacomodar dele para
contribuir uma mudança efetiva que tinha
é possível no trabalho na universidade
na escola no teu bairro nos espaços de
lazer em todos esses lugares existem
desigualdades que combinam raça e gênero
é só procurar primeiro íntimo nos seus
privilégios e depois na tua vontade
vamos Muito obrigado a